As if we needed to up the stakes in today's
election, as if the country's future wasn't
already riding on this election.
We have another wrinkle.
New report by The New York Times, as well
as by Best Leaven in Vanity Fair reveals that
Donald Trump is not just looking to win because
he is a narcissistic egomaniac.
He's also reportedly terrified about going
to prison if he loses today's election.
This is not just based on existing investigations,
but on potential new ones.
He expects, quote from the New York Times
article, Seldom, far from Trump's thoughts
is the possibility of defeat and the potential
consequences of being ejected from the White
House in unguarded moments.
Trump has for weeks told advisers he expects
to face intensifying scrutiny from prosecutors
if he loses.
He is concerned not only about existing investigations
in New York, but the potential for new federal
probes as well.
According to people who have spoken with him,
The New Yorker's Jane Mayer has similar reporting.
She writes, quote, Trump's legal expenses
alone are likely to be daunting.
By the time Bill Clinton left the White House,
he'd racked up more than 10 million in legal
fees.
And Trump's finances are already under growing
strain during the next four years, according
to a stunning recent Times report.
Trump, whether reelected or not, must meet
payment deadlines for more than 300 million
dollars in loans that he has personally guaranteed.
Much of his debt is owed to such foreign creditors
as Deutsche Bank.
Unless he can refinance with the lenders,
he will be on the hook.
Cornered animals become desperate.
Donald Trump is very cornered right now.
One of the reasons he's desperate to win is
the concern about being prosecuted.
Now, also, fascinatingly, from the New York
Times piece, Donald Trump has people around
him telling him he's definitely going to win
tonight.
Listen to this quote.
The president, his associates say, has drawn
encouragement from his larger audiences and
from a stream of relatively upbeat polling
information that advisers have curated for
him, typically filtering out the bleakest
numbers.
On a trip to Florida last week, several aides
told the president that winning the Electoral
College was a certainty, a prognosis not supported
by Republican or Democratic polling.
Mark Meadows, chief of staff, has responded
with chipper enthusiasm when Trump raised
the idea of making a late bid for solidly
Democratic states like New Mexico, New Mexico,
an option other aides have told the president
is flatly unrealistic.
This is important because when Trump says
he's winning everything at his rallies, if
people around Trump are actually telling him,
you've got this, you've got the Electoral
College.
If he doesn't win it, he will definitely think
it was rigged.
If you're thinking I'm down seven, but maybe
I can pull this off.
If you don't win, you sort of are expecting
it.
If everybody around you is saying you're going
to win the Electoral College and you don't,
you react very differently and you probably
do all the things we're worried Donald Trump
is going to do.
Now, fortunately or unfortunately for Trump
versus for the country, the country does not
have a history of prosecuting past presidents.
That suggests Trump doesn't need to worry.
But past presidents also haven't had this
level of corruption in their past.
So it could change if everything that should
be investigated is investigated whenever the
time comes.
The Trump family would likely be tied up in
court for a long time.
To be perfectly frank, probably through the
rest of Donald Trump's life, Trump being prosecuted
would be a tremendously lovely ending.
But Trump out of office is the goal right
now.
We have the opportunity to do it today.
And I hope you'll join me tonight.
I will be streaming live starting at 7:00
p.m. Eastern, 4:00 p.m. Pacific as the results
start coming in on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
Do not miss it.